100 millions 400 000 dollars c'est la
somme que le gouvernement Trudeau a
versé à la firmeckenzie depuis son
arrivée au pouvoir en 2015 des dizaines
de contrats parfois octroyés sans appel
d'offres j'étais déjà inquiet je suis
très inquiet ok je suis très inquiet de
voir ça de lire des choses que je lis ça
me semble un peu irréaliste des
informations obtenues par Radio-Canada
révèle que le ministère de la Défense
nationale la version au moins 34
millions de dollars au cabinet conseil
depuis 2021 des contrats signés pour la
modernisation de la Marine canadienne la
promotion de la diversité culturelle à
la défense ou encore pour moderniser le
système de gestion des plaintes des
conduites sexuelles dans l'armée mais
Kenzie sont probablement très compétents
mais bon à tout puis partout puis dans
les dans les conditions qu'on voit là
moi je trouve ça 100 millions en 7 ans
là c'est beaucoup d'argent pour le
contribuer le gouvernement après avoir
fait front commun en début de semaine
afin de forcer la tenue d'une enquête
Parlement faire les parties d'opposition
réclament plus que jamais des réponses
du gouvernement Trudeau
c'est du copinage du gaspillage pourquoi
on a donné ses contrats là pourquoi
cette ferme-là systématiquement et
qu'est-ce qu'on a obtenu comme résultat
ça semble assez pauvre ça s'est rendu
maintenant presque un billet de saison
ou un guichet automatique pour cette
entreprise là il faut aller au fond des
choses alors plus ça va plus on en
apprend davantage et plus ça démontre la
pertinence de la volonté exprimée par
notre chef cette semaine il faut qu'il y
ait un comité parlementaire qui se passe
là-dessus le gouvernement AB son
leadership et fait payer le prix en
double au contribuant pour les décisions
qui sont prises par la suite et dont on
constate de plus en plus qu'elles ne
sont pas nécessairement les plus adaptés
nous allons faire un suivi sous pression
depuis le début de l'année Justin
Trudeau a promis de pencher sur la ferme
il est chargé il est ministre de la
provisionnement et du Conseil du Trésor
de faire la lumière sur les contrats
octroyés mais Kenzi rien pour convaincre
les parties d'opposition et pour
l'instant ni le cabinet du premier
ministre ni la firmeckenzin a voulu
parler à Radio-Canada